I continue to try to find the best
headphones for preparing the david
pakman show and I was recently sent the
sound in tone CX 05 headphones with
microphone and i recently tried them out
and i really like them i'ma tell you
about them real quick the thing I like
most about these headphones is just the
sturdy construction you actually have uh
not only a layer of fabric for increased
comfort but you might see that the head
beam here is uh metallic and it just is
really really sturdy and they fold open
fold clothes which is super convenient
and when you actually put them on I have
to admit when I picked them up they were
so light I was sort of thinking yeah I
don't know that this is really going to
have good quality sound uh but they did
and I tried them out with my phone I've
got Spotify on there I've got stitcher
on there I'm doing all sorts of stuff
there uh and I thought that the sound
quality was absolutely tremendous so I
would encourage you to check out the CX
05 headphones we have a twenty percent
off coupon code if you use the link in
the description to this video that
coupon code is for GV for d w b v that
is again for GV for d w b v and you can
use that when buying them off of amazon
using the link in the video description
i've been using these now for a few days
when i do my show prep as the egg man
likes to refer to it and they've been
absolutely fantastic